>>Roy Spence: Here's the deal with Roy's hot
sauce.
My dad lived to be 95 years old, passed away
two years ago, grew up in Eagle Pass Texas,
spoke Spanish before English, his name was
Roy, he was 6'5"; I have no idea what happened.
So they've called me Royito all my life; little
Roy.
If you go to my hometown in Brownwood I'm
still Royito.
He taught me three things; be kind to everybody
you meet cause everyone's fightin' some kind
of battle.
Simplify your life; I screwed that up so bad,
we'll talk about that but I did and don't
do mild in anything.
So the purpose on my jar is to encourage the
young and the young at heart to don't do mild
in life.
Follow your dreams, follow your passion, follow
your purpose.
And we're gonna talk a little bit about that
today because the miracle of this country
is entrepreneurship.
And your founders are entrepreneurs and we
gotta make sure we rebirth that whole energy
in your part of this movement.
And we need to not occupy anything; we need
to get preoccupied with getting the young
and young at heart to go start businesses
again.
We'll talk a little bit more about that.
I love what your founders said, by the way,
about the, I hope I don't have a Rick Perry
moment here but I have to remember 10 things
he only had to remember 3 come on.
3?
I wanna cut the secretary of state, cut the
secretary, whatever!
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: I love him.
I love you, don't ever change, don't, and
don't get elected.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: But its okay, I'm not afraid
to shit; you know what I'm saying?
I'm just not.
If he wants to retaliate, go, come on, they
know where I live, I know where he lives.
Hi, love you.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: So when your founders talked
about the 10 things they know to be true,
that's pretty bold when you're 8 years old,
to say that you know the 10 things that you
know to be true.
But, I went through them all.
Number one, if you serve the user everything
else will follow.
Sam Walton taught me, Sam loved me cause his
dog was named old Roy.
It's true.
And Sam Walton used to say it this way; give
the customer what they want not what you want
them to want and they'll beat the path to
your door.
At GSD&M this is the way we say it; we'll
do whatever it takes to build our clients
business cause when they build their, when
we build their business they'll build ours.
What you know to be the truth, and it's number
one on that list, is that you focus on the
user and everything else will follow.
Secondly they say it's really, really, really
better to focus on one thing and be really,
really, really good at it.
I don't know if you read Jim Collins's book
but he talks about the difference between
a little bit less hedgehog and a fox.
A hedgehog you just stayed focused and you
go do it and us foxes, I'm not going by the
way I look but as foxes we just go running
around and shit, you know, doing stuff except
Thomas actually said I was a hedgehog cause
all the running around I do doesn't seem like
it makes any sense, really, but I found out
a long time ago that my purpose is to help
others fulfill theirs.
So it's running Clinton for president or working
the state department or doing BMW, I run around
trying to help people fulfill their purpose.
I do have ADD and I bought a t-shirt in Aspen
two weeks ago and it says "I don't have ADD,
oh is that a bunny running?"
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: You know what I'm talking about?
I got it.
So, focus on the user, do one thing really,
really, really good, I love this one, fast
is better than slow.
I think about what a truth; fast is better
than slow.
At the University of Texas we used to say
winning was better than losing.
I had to explain it to the Aggies but it's
a long road to go down that road to figure
that out.
It is.
[Laughs]
>>Roy Spence: Fast is better than slow.
And then I love the idea that you don't have
to be at your desk to need an answer.
It's a brilliant truth.
In fact, I wear a pedometer.
I do at least 12,000 steps a day.
It's my curiosity meter, literally.
I know that you all have a lot of stuff to
do and you gotta do it but if you don't do
at least 10,000 to 12,000 steps a day you're
not out there enough.
So every day, this is weird and, again, nobody
knows this but you, and won't tell anybody,
you just run Google, anyway.
[Laughs]
>>Roy Spence: I send an email to myself every
morning at 4 in the morning and it says, "I
wonder what the world has in store for me
today.
I think I'll go find out."
I wonder what the world has in store for me
today.
I think I'll go find out.
You don't have to be at your desk to need
an answer.
I love the idea, another truth that democracy
works on the web.
And working at the state department the last
couple years and seeing what's happened around
the world, democracy works on the web.
And before Al Gore and I invented it there
was a way to keep things secret and there's
not a way anymore.
And democracy, my mom taught Civics for 35
years, taught me too, from a small town, I
did really well on her tests since I graded
them when I was 7, 8, 9 and 10.
And she told me two things, don't call me
mom in class and don't sell the tests to your
friends.
So I did both.
Anyway,
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: I'm an entrepreneur, you got
to-- my mother said no matter how bad it gets
in politics, politics is the business of freedom.
No matter how rough it gets and how nasty
it gets, always remember politics is the business
of freedom.
Another truth that your founder said was that
"There's always more information out there."And
George Carver Washington, who's really one
of my heroes, you probably don't know much
about him but he was born in 1864, son of
a slave family and invented the idea of rotating
crops which is revolutionary coming from a
small town, a farming town.
You rotate the crops to keep the nutrients
in.
He said this, he said that, "Education and
knowledge are the golden keys to freedom."
That's not bad.
In fact, I don't think ya'll are in the tech
business I think you're in the freedom business,
we'll talk more about that.
Another truth that your founders say that
"The need for information crosses all borders"
another truth and I know that first hand when
we helped create, with Bill Clinton, the Clinton
Global Initiative.
I was at the White House the last night that
Bill was president.
He kept saying, "Don't leave.
Don't leave.
Come down."
It's 2 in the morning, puts his arm and says,
"What do I do next?"
I said, "Well, first of all, you can't stay
here."
[Laughs]
>>Roy Spence: We worked through that for about
3 or 4 hours and I said, "Arkansas had you
for 16 years, America had you for 8, now the
world needs you."
And he talks about this whole idea of information
with no borders.
He says this, "We can't create a better future
for America unless we help others create a
better future for them."
At some point we're all in this together,
and he believes a lot because of what ya'll
are doing, that in the end there will be no
them it'll only be us.
I wrote that line, it's a good line isn't
it?
There is no them it's only us.
This is one of my favorite truths; you can
be serious and not wear a tie or a suit.
What people don't know, I know why we had
the economic meltdown, it wasn't AIG, it wasn't
Fannie Mae, it wasn't Bush administration,
it was white guys in ties.
Now here's what, it's true, Harvard did a
study, Harvard did a study, 20 year study
of people who wore ties 5 days a week and
people who didn't, guys.
They found out after 20 years that ties cut
off 21 percent of the circulation of oxygen
to your brain and 28 percent to your heart.
I just made that shit up.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: No, I did.
>>Roy Spence: And people, no I did, I just
made it up.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: And people, I do this and people
start un tightening their tie, but it's true.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: You can use it, just make it
up.
People don't know.
Well, I guess that's not in the spirit of
transparency but you can be serious and not
wear a suit.
Thank you.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: Next to the last one is so great
and it says something like, you know, "Great
isn't good enough."
And Emerson, my favorite poet besides Frost,
said it this way, "What lies behind you and
what lies in front of you is tiny compared
with what lies inside you."
And the idea that great isn't good enough
is at, not just your company, but if you want
to really put that search engine that you
have for everybody to your own self, what
lies inside of you is what really will decide
whether you're happy or not.
And the final one is don't do evil.
And that's really important when you have
access to so much.
And that's really what I wanna talk about
today, if you don't mind, just a little bit
about the power of purpose and the fact that
you can make money by making a difference.
And you can make money by doing no evil.
And by the way, if we don't do that as a business
community, you'll see what happens to businesses.
So I'm hopeful but if we all become purpose
inspired organizations full of purpose inspired
people, you can make a lot of money but make
a difference and you don't have to do evil.
It's a fine line in your business, by the
way, cause sometimes you don't mean to do
evil and it gets done and then you just gotta
fess up when you mess up.
So, here's my journey.
Went to the University of Texas, I met my
four partners in 1970, school sucked, really,
I wanted to go out there and do something
else.
So, it was the age of Marshall McLuhan, you
don't know who he is but, well now you do
cause you got all those music rooms, but he
used to say, "The medium's the message."
Now how relevant is that today when you think
of Google?
So we did multimedia shows and our company
was called Media 70.
And I learned, we did multimedia shows and
passed out brownies, you know what I'm talking
about.
So, and everybody paid, everybody paid us.
It was awesome.
So, uh, cut that out.
[Laughter]
[Pause]
>>Roy Spence: And I learned my first marketing
lesson.
Everything was great with Media 70 until January
1st, 1971.
Don't name your company after a year, just
don't do it.
Brazil 66 or whatever.
So we graduated from college, one of my partners
sold the G in GSD&M, sold ads at the Daily
Texan.
So why don't we start an ad agency?
I said, "Well, great.
What is one?"
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: Gives our clients a lot of confidence.
So we decided to start an ad agency.
I went down to the bank, had a brand new tie
dyed t-shirt and my pony tail was lookin'
awesome.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: I went into, the loan officer's
name was John Oliver, and I said, "John, you
don't know me, I don't know you but you need
to loan me $5,000 dollars for my business."
He was one of those guys [inaudible].
And he said, "What's your business?" and I
said, "Making money, what's yours?"
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: And he loaned us the money and
we paid it back a couple weeks ago.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: But, my first lesson besides
my mom, my dad and my sister on purpose was
about 10 years ago we went to a reception
in Austin.
A guy walks up to me and he said, "See that
older gentleman over there with a cane?
Do you know who he is?"
I went, "Yeah, he was my mentor in college.
He could tell I needed one pretty bad.
His name is Robert Sneed."
He said, "You remember that loan that you
got 25 years ago?"
I said, "Like it was yesterday."
And he said, "You know that he cosigned that
note and never told you cause he wanted you
to believe that you got it on your own?"
That first little lesson, all you young people,
somebody helps you, you gotta help somebody
else.
That's the way it works.
This world would be a lot better, just that
chain reaction.
Everybody has to have a helping hand every
now and then.
But you just store that back and when somebody
else needs it you give too and the only thing
you ask them to do is pass that on.
And then I met Herb Keller, I was 28 years
old, he had 28 airplanes.
He took a chance on us and he taught me so
much; how to drink and smoke on the job.
I introduced him into the National Hall of
Fame dinner the other night in New York; he
was the first CEO to ever get elected into
the advertising hall of fame that had no advertising.
And I told him that I didn't know he drank
until one day he came into a meeting sober.
[Laughs]
>>Roy Spence: But, I'll tell you what he taught
me and it's important for Google; take the
competition seriously but not yourself.
Take some yeast, lighten up.
I don't think I have to tell ya'll that but
this is about having fun.
Do no evil and have fun.
And by the way, he was a fierce competitor.
And then Sam Walton came into my life because
he was in the rural areas, loved what we were
doing for Southwest, picked up the phone,
he called me, "Roy will you come to Bentonville?"
I got on a plane, flew from here to Dallas,
changed planes, flew to Fort Smith, then flew
to Fayetteville and then rented a car, went
through hogeye and honkey town and got to
Bentonville and I thought I'd gone to heaven
cause my dad was a sales person.
So I sit in a room and there were 8 people
and Sam was sitting there and he said, "So,
lil Roy, where's the rest of your staff?"And
they were staring at me just like you are
right now and I said, "Well there's an old
Texas saying, one riot, one ranger.
What problem you got?"
Didn't even blink, I didn't blink.
"So, what's your problem?"
So they hired me before I got out the door.
I tell you what, I traveled with Sam Walton
and he taught me one great lesson; curiosity
does not kill the cat, it kills the competition.
Curiosity meter.
He used to make us go into Kmart and find
something better that they did than we did,
it was hard.
It was really hard.
And he would always start his meetings, he'd
get down on one knee and he'd say, "I know
what I know, I wanna know what you know."
And then he had a little yellow tablet, he
didn't know about the computer thing, and
he'd write it down.
You go to Bentonville and there's a little
museum, all of his yellow tablets, he kept
them all, 40 years.
I know what I know I wanna know what you know.
And then one of the great lessons I learned
at the University of Texas, I actually did
go to a class when I was a senior, you know,
wrote down a few things, and so I had a final
and an essay, cause, you know, multiple choices
you have to know stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
So I would always opt out.
I'd go find a class where you could write
bullshit, basically.
So, anyway, I went to the test, did the little
bluebook thing, wrote it down, aced it, turned
it in.
Two weeks later I got it back and I got a
C on it.
You would know who I'm talking about if I
gave you the name of the professor.
I went to the professor and I said, "You don't
understand
[Clears throat]
>>Roy Spence: there's no way I could make
a C. I took your lecture down word for word."
And he said, "Well, I guess I just gave a
C lecture."
I guess I just gave a C lecture.
Here's the point.
Just when you think you've got it knocked
and you're at the top of the hill and you've
aced it, there's gonna be something that hits
Google, hits you in your life, so you gotta,
as Hakeem Olajuwon used to say in Houston,
"You gotta stay humble and stay hungry."
Mainly stay humble because tomorrow morning
you don't know what's gonna happen.
Stay humble, stay thankful, stay hungry.
And then I had all these other mentors in
my life, it was just amazing, you know, from
Charles Schwab to the Clinton's and all this
journey but I'll tell you a quick story before
we get to the real meat of this.
I've been married 34 years; I promised my
wife that if we ever had children I'd never
miss one of their birthdays.
Now you would say, well of course you're not
gonna miss one of their birthdays but we have
no clients in Austin.
It's sad that the people that know us the
best don't hire us but that's another thing
I'm working through.
[Clears throat]
>>Roy Spence: But PGA tour, DreamWorks, United
States Air Force, so they don't call up and
say, "Hey Roy can you come see me?"
"Yes, sir General."
"By the way is tomorrow one of your kid's
birthdays?"
So I did great with my two girls and then
my son turned 15 and I get the emergency call.
So I'm in this, in this thing and I realize,
by that way I never wear a watch, but I wasn't
gonna make it home for my son's birthday.
So I asked these two guys if they would do
something for my son.
So I'm gonna play this video, if you would
and then I'm gonna tell you why I played it.
[Applause]
>>Roy Spence: I got home at 2 to midnight
and Jay was 15, he had a bunch of girlfriends
over and just a little bit of envy but not
much.
These two guys hadn't talked to each other
in about 5 years and that tsunami hit 2000
miles away.
Bill had just had quadruple bypass surgery
and we went to Little Rock Arkansas and these
two people put purpose above politics and
they put purpose above pettiness and we raised
2 billion dollars in 5 days.
American people need to see more of this.
We think we're in the political business but
we're not, we're in the purpose business and
America's got to get back to its purpose.
Politicians need to understand they're not
in the reelection business anymore; they have
to be in the make a difference business.
So when Katrina hit I got them together again
and they formed that fund for Katrina.
When Ike hit Houston President Bush called
Bill Clinton, we filmed them.
When Haiti, a horrible earth-- I just got
back from Haiti, the earthquake hit, I got
W and Clinton together, that was an interesting
shoot.
I feel like I'm the frickin' eHarmony
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: for politicians.
But the truth is that I know that politics
has to go on but sooner or later you have
to put the purpose of this country ahead of
the politics of the party.
And the American people are waiting for this.
By the way, when I was filming the first one,
Bill Clinton looked at me and the tsunami
and he said, "You know the animals left before
the tsunami hit."
They left.
The American people have left and we're sitting
there going who's gonna step up and tell us
where we should go fighting?
But what are we fighting for?
Instead of fighting, in a democracy, by the
way, if you don't have something to fight
for you fight against each other.
So I play that because that's the purpose
at work.
So we're gonna cover some quick ground.
Talk about the economy just for a little bit.
I wanna talk about what purpose is, why do
you need it?
What does it look like, sound like?
And why Robert Frost was writing?
Quickly, we're not in a recession, we're not
in a depression; we're in a generational winter.
There's a book called The Fourth Turning by
Neil Howe and Bill Strauss, they're the ones
that wrote the generations book, they're the
ones who named the millennials, I don't know
if you like them or not but they're generational
experts.
And the premise of the book documented is
that every generation goes through a spring,
summer, fall and winter.
The last winter America had was World War
Two in the Great Depression.
That was my parent's winter.
The winter before that was the Civil War.
The winter before that was the American Revolution.
And they've tracked it all throughout Europe.
So we're in an economic winter and that, in
fact, they wrote the book The Fourth Turning
in 1998 and they predicted our winter would
hit in 2008.
Let me repeat what I just said.
They wrote it in 1998 and they predicted our
winter would hit in 2008.
I know you all haven't suffered through the
winter like a lot of other organizations,
good job.
In every other winter we've had, I said it
before; the American people knew what we were
fighting for.
In World War Two it was freedom itself.
In the Civil War which was the worst war we
were ever in, we were fighting to see whether
or not we had the courage to keep this thing
together.
And the American Revolution we were fighting
to create the birth of new democracy.
The reason we're in a stalemate right now
is that we don't know what we're fighting
for.
And it's not cap and trade and it's not fighting
for healthcare and it's not-- those are tactics.
If you hear from Washington, here are the
solutions; either spin and stimulate or cut
and stay, those are the solutions.
You what we have to do?
We have to create our way outta this business.
Between 1985 and 2005, America created 41
million jobs.
85 to 2005, 92 percent with companies less
than 5 years old.
The miracle of America is entrepreneurship.
So in this winter here's what happened.
Before the winter the world economy was propped
up by the American consumer spending more
than we had on things we didn't need, made
some place else.
Let me go through again.
The whole world economy was based upon the
American consumer spending more than we had
on things we didn't need made some place else.
We bought so much stuff we had to get off
sight storage to go visit it.
We were spending, by the way I have duct tape
on my wallet that's another story, but we
were spending 144 dollars a day.
That's not mortgage that's discretionary income.
And when the winter hit it went down to 44
dollars, let's see.
And outside of this spending right now in
this Christmas holidays it's averaging out
63 dollars.
So 144 to 63, the American people have said
I think I'm not gonna do more with less I
think I'm gonna do better with less.
Here's the good news for Google.
If a business is not in the business of improving
people's lives they're not gonna be in business.
And they're gonna find out, that's why my
book, best seller, what, it's not what you
sell it's what you stand for.
Because everyone's selling the same kind of
stuff and what you stand for is gonna be just
as important.
So if you're in the life improvement business
and with your folks here and the enterprise
group, I don't think you're in the consulting
business, I don't think you're in the selling
of high tech stuff, I think you're in the
business to improve your clients life so they
can improve the life of their business , so
they can improve the life of their employees
and whether it's, you know, earth builder
or earth pro or that mapping thing that, what
is it that you find where crime is and shit?
It's unbelievable.
No, I was blown away.
I didn't want my address on your Google map
but anyway, what you're doing everyday is
empowering people to be free and do good things
for their company.
And if you're from the offers, anyone from
the offers segment?
Okay, two things real quick.
I know you know this but we don't see this
much in Austin but we're still the consumers
are in deep, deep trouble.
If you do not get your offers out to them
you're cheating them out of the opportunity
of leading a good life for less.
It's not just selling coupons and discounts,
you're selling what counts.
Is that right?
And by the way, what you're doing to help
small businesses is the miracle of America,
we gotta have a rebirth.
So all the time when you're walking, talking
about small businesses and mom and pops, we
need to create a million new businesses a
year in America to get this country going
again.
A million.
And all of them need mentors.
So I'm gonna do a TV show, I'm selling it
right now called Dream it, Build it, I'm the
host.
And we go find a dreamer.
Google ought to do this shit, we ought to
put it up, seriously, I've got Howard Schultz,
I've got Herb Keller, I've got the woman that
built the company Build a Bear, I've got Chris
Gardner who you, he was the original guy in
the Pursuit of Happiness, I have every mentor
already lined up.
And we're gonna go out and find dreamers in
every category.
I wanna open a restaurant, I wanna be a farmer
and we're gonna have the American people vote
on it, not like you have to sing and shit.
It's gonna be literally, you know, another
little whatever, and then at the end, so I
introduce the dreamer, I partner them with
a mentor and at the end of the show just like
that Robert Sneed who lent me the 5,000 dollars,
everybody who's built a business said somebody
helped them and so at that moment in time
they're gonna have a pass it forward moment
to that dreamer.
And the only requirement is the dreamer has
to report in every month on our website, dreamitbuildi.biz
how they're doing.
We're gonna every night when the call to action
is, there are 40 million in America, by the
way, I didn't make this up like the Harvard
stuff, there are 40 million people, but you
don't know the difference so what the hell?
There's 40 million people in this country
who basically go home at night and dream about
opening up their own business.
I saw some of you look at yourselves, watch
out they may leave, but anyway, we need, I
need to get Google involved with this because
this is gonna be a movement that literally
saves the republic.
And we represent AARP although I'm not a member
and we're gonna launch a campaign next year
called Relaunch Your Life.
People, the young and the young at heart,
so what you're doing with offers and what
you're doing with enterprise, all of you can
do the big stuff at some point, I know you
do this, make sure, make sure, you might pick
5 businesses and you're in Austin Texas and
help them grow.
You might find dreamers of your own and pick
them.
Let them come up here and find out, I don't
do mild award with the Rise Group and I give
part of the proceeds of Royito to the entrepreneur.
But this is something I know ya'll are involved
with but the more you can be involved with
rebirthing and reigniting the American dream,
that'll keep you humble.
We gotta stand tall for small.
So, what is purpose?
Aristotle said it the best, and by the way
I'm talking to you about your own life too
if you don't mind, not just about Google.
Aristotle said, "Purpose is where your talent
and the needs of the world intersect.
Therein lies your vocation."
Where your talents and the needs of the world
intersect, therein lies your purpose.
You ever heard the Peter's principal?
People get burned out?
When I was in the 8th grade I turned in a
paper on Emerson and I had 29 misspelled words
and I got a C. C's were not acceptable in
our household.
The next year we did Emerson again with another
teacher and I told my mom I'm not turning
this paper in.
I was scared to death.
She said, "No, go ahead."
I had 32 misspelled words and got an A+.
So I brought both the papers home and I said,
"I don't get this."
And my mom said, "You can't spell."
Hire one.
But there was a point she said, "You can write
your ass off."
Purpose is about not spending your life trying
to become average at what you're bad at.
Purpose is spending your life becoming great
at what you're good at.
I always tell my kids, and they're all doing
it, you can make a living doing what you love
to do.
I'm not saying you'll get rich but there's
a lot of definitions of rich.
You can make a living at what you love to
do.
So purpose is that definitive statement of
the difference you're trying to make in the
world.
We've been blessed with a purpose institute
which our separate company from GSD&M now
but we did all the way in our business.
Southwest Airline purpose, we're not in the
airline business.
Our purpose is real simple; we give people
the freedom to fly.
By the way, ya'll give people the freedom
to thrive.
I think that's copyrightable, cut that out,
you gotta pay me for this shit I'm not giving
it away.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: Okay, and ya'll have money,
fine Southwest Airlines purpose, we give people
the freedom to fly.
Wal-Mart, our purpose is save people money.
By the way, I always say when we're at our
best, cause sometimes you're not always at
your best as a company, we save people money
so they can live better.
United States Air Force, by the way, thank
them, when we're at our best we protect you
from attacks from air space and cyber space
and maybe you all can work with them, I'm
sure you do here.
John Mackey and whole foods, our purpose,
when we're at our best we nourish the body
and the mind and the soul and the community
and the planet.
In Disney when we're at our best we use our
imagination to bring happiness to millions.
Apple when we're at our best we create beautiful
things for the mind that enhances human kind.
When I talk about Google, all this a little
bit, it's not exactly your words, here's what
I say, people go crazy you can use it if you
want to, I said, "Google's purpose is, when
they're at their best, they organize all the
information there ever was and there ever
will be and make it accessible and useful
to all people for all time."
That's called a [inaudible].
People go, "I wanna do that."
I said, "Don't.
They're already doing it."
But in a sense that's what you do.
You organize all the information there ever
was, ever will be and make it useful and accessible
to all people for all time.
You democratize knowledge every day.
The GE aviation, I was talking to 7,000 scientists,
they were really inspired by me but finally
about half through the deal I said, "Ya'll
aren't really paying attention but it's either
my fault or yours, so I've got the mic and
I'm saying it's yours, so there."
I did, it was funny.
Cause I don't give a shit, so I said, "Do
you know what your founders said about your
company?
You know what your founders said about GE?
And by the way, it wasn't Jack Welch."
They went, "Really?"
"It's a guy named Thomas Edison.
And you know what he said?
I never perfect an invention that I don't
think about the impact on the greater good."
So we went through this whole purpose project
with GE aviation, people that build the jet
engines.
At the end, by the way you can't make up purpose;
it's got to be authentic.
In the end we presented it to all the staff,
what we found out, and here's their purpose,
we don't build jet engines we invent the future
of flight.
It lifts people up and brings them home safely.
That company's now on fire.
I don't like to use that word with jet engines.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: I don't even know why I said
that but it is so excited about the fact that
we're not just in the jet engine business
we invent the future of flight.
So every day that you wake up go back and
look at your statement about that user and
organizing all the information there ever
will be and make it accessible and available
and useful to all people for all time.
And in sense what you do, you give them the
freedom to thrive.
That's what you do.
That's a pretty good business to be in.
So why do you need it?
It drives every decision, it helps you don't
do evil.
The Southwest Airlines, let's put up a little
slide here or you can go anywhere if you want
to.
Anyway
[Laughs]
>>Roy Spence: Southwest Airlines, there was
2 monkeys in a bar and so, here, okay here's
the story, 10 months ago, they paid me to
do this shit, this is not hard.
No it really isn't but I make it really hard
and whatever, so
[Laughs]
>>Roy Spence: the consultants walk in and
they said, "You're losing and leaving 350
million dollars on the table not charging
for bags.
Now, American Airlines just went bankrupt
today.
[Makes crying noise]
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: So, and you know why they go
bankrupt?
So they can keep their cost down so they can
compete with us.
We've never been bank, you know that Southwest
Airlines is the most unionized airline in
America, did you know that?
We've never had a strike, we've never had
a furlough, we've never went, we've never
had a prob, a quarter we hadn't made money
and we haven't gone bankrupt so we get our
costs down on the backs of our vendors.
I'm not pissed off about it, but anyway, here's
the point, they said, "You're leaving 350
million dollars, everybody's doing it.
Everybody's charging for bags."
So another consultant walked in, I said, "Do
whatever you want.
You charge for bags, you violate the purpose
of the company, your call.
It's that simple.
We're in the business to give people the freedom
to fly but we do it by keeping our cost down
so we can keep our fares down so we can give
people the freedom to fly.
We see a time where everyone can go and see
and do things they only dreamed of.
So you charge for bags there's gonna be a
lot of people that can't go to Disney.
It's your call."
Hurt the little children.
[Laughter]
>>Roy Spence: When Gary Kelly stood up and
said, "We're not gonna charge for bags, you
go find the money."
So we launched this campaign, I'll play the
commercial and I'll tell you what happened.
About 3 months ago the CFO comes into the
meeting and sits down with everyone and he
said, "I was wrong."
I said, "Excuse me?"
Did you see King's Speech?
One of the greatest movies ever, I'm serious.
He said, "I was wrong."
"Oh, what'd ya say?
You were wrong?"
"I was wrong!"
In 12 months we generated 1.2 billion dollars
in sales charging for free because we stood
firm on our purpose.
And you know what happens when you stand firm
on your purpose?
Consumers can smell it.
I wanna hang around you guys.
There are two type of companies; there are
vinegar companies and there are honey companies.
Some you just don't wanna be around.
By the way, there's two kind of people.
There are takers and there are givers.
I like givers.
I like honey.
A great brand is always a honey brand.
People say I wanna hang out with you because
I agree with what you stand for.
I wanna hang out with you instead of, "Oh
God."
And play like you're on the phone, he's coming.
I wanna hang out with you cause I like what
you stand for.
So what does purpose look like?
I'm gonna play 3 or 4 spots and these are
probono.
If we have a lot of time at our agency we
try to do the right thing, the first spot,
this is what purpose looks like.
The first spot I wanna tell a little story,
we were in Annapolis when 9/11 happened.
We had 2 clients involved, the United States
Air Force and Southwest Airlines.
And by the way, we had just got the Air Force
and their theme line was nobody comes close.
Oops.
They bombed the Pentagon.
So we were going home, driving home, trying
to get home and I kept saying, "What can we
do?
What can we do?"
So I called every director in America and
said, "I want ya'll to go out and film people
of every race, every religion, every color
saying one thing, I'm an American."
Because I was worried in the process of striking
back our enemies we might strike one of our
own because they look different.
So this first spot aired more times than any
other PSA in history and then it just went
again on the 10th anniversary.
So this is what purpose looks like.
Purpose doesn't have to be heavy; you just
have to have one.
83 percent of all responders are trained at
community colleges and we're about to cut
community college's budget in half around
this country.
So, by the way if you can learn to drink coffee
without a cigarette you can learn to do anything.
We have a whole series them, um, you got a
smoke?
But, uh, I wanna play 4 other spots, these
are like paying clients and then, everyone
that we represent has a purpose beyond making
money or we don't represent them.
They might not know it but we help them understand
what their core purpose is.
So let's just play these spots.
The real thrill when you have purpose on your
side is that you get people to smile or laugh
or think or cry and not just sit there.
Cause if it just sits there, that spot or
whatever runs on any of the media, if it just
sits there it doesn't activate somebody's
emotion, it's not worth it.
Real quick story and we're gonna wrap up pretty
soon.
I get a call from one of my colleagues from
Wal-Mart who's a pharmacist and ended up being
head of merchandise worldwide for the largest
company in the world and he retired about
3 years ago and he retired, he's young but,
and he said he needed to have tractor time.
So John Deere's our client so, anyway, so
he called me up and he said, "I wanna repay
a favor that you gave me when I was at Wal-Mart"
and I said, "Well, I didn't do anything."
He said, "No, I used to think in black and
white and you helped me think in color.
So I'm gonna send you a video cause this is
what purpose sounds like.
I know what it looks like I wanna teach you
what it sounds like.
And when you get done hearing the video I
want you to call me the next morning and I'll
tell you why this is what purpose sounds like."
So I wanna play you this and then I'll tell
you what he said.
I called him up the next day, by the way,
I watch that every morning, but I said, "So,
it's awesome but tell me why this is what
purpose sounds like."
And he said, "Well, first of all everybody's
gotta know the words to the song.
Secondly, you gotta listen to one another.
Third, you gotta step up when it's your turn.
Fourth, it sounds awesome when you sing together.
And fifth, it helps to have a good song to
sing."
So, if you work in an organization that has
a good song to sing, by the way America has
a good song to sing we just don't know the
words to the song anymore and we don't listen
to one another anymore and we don't step up
when it's our turn anymore and that's gotta
change.
If you work for an awesome company you gotta
know the words to the song, you gotta listen
to one another, you gotta step up when it's
your turn and by the way, when you sing together
it's pretty awesome.
You guys have a good song to sing.
And final, why Robert Frost was writing, you
thought I'd forget that one.
But, I was in New York about 3 years ago and
it was late night and I was flipping through
there and flipping through the kid channels
and kept going to the channel company that
Nancy Grace, that everybody's bad, every aunt
kills their nephew, every dog kills their
priest, every, whatever and I was just going,
I went, "Oh my God."
And I said, I remember what that great philosopher,
French philosopher said, "America will cease
to be great if we cease to be good.
So this is not the America I know so I decided,
you'll get the logic, to walk across America.
Where, you know, so, it's hard, you have the
same look as when I told my wife.
She said, "Whatever."
So, I got on Google Maps with my assistant
and I stated in Cobham New Hampshire and walked
through seven states on my first leg with
a backpack and two American flags.
And I had a pedometer that beeped every mile
and the theory was, and it worked out that
I was gonna take a picture of something good
every mile.
And I was run off the road, I was in mud,
even though when it beeped I had to find something
good and take a picture.
And this is why Robert Frost was writing,
"There are two roads diverged in a yellow
wood in life.
And sorry, I can't travel both and be one
traveler."
I didn't know what that meant when my mom
used to read it to me.
Two roads diverged and I cannot travel both
and be one traveler.
So I found on this first leg of the journey,
thank you Google Maps, that you become what
you look for in life.
If you look for enemies you'll find them.
If you look for hate it'll live in your heart.
If you look for gossip it'll consume you.
If you look for fear it'll follow you.
But on that other road, if you look for friends
you'll be befriended.
And if you look for love it'll lift you up.
And if you look for the truth it'll set you
free.
And if you look for hope it'll take you to
higher ground.
That's the road I'm on.
And I wish I'd of known that road a long,
long time ago but instinctively I think I've
been on that road all along.
So you look for friends and you look for love
and you look for the truth and you look for
hope and in the process in business you'll
make money but you'll make a difference and
just perhaps you'll make a little bit of history.
That's not a bad way to live your life in
business.
So I thank you for inviting me, Patrick, and
thank you for being in Austin.
I wish you a purpose inspired life and 'Hook
'em.'
[Applause]